all right so we're told that vector V is
equal to X comma y so they're not giving
us the actual numbers for the X
component and the y component they're
just saying the X component is going to
be the variable x and the y component is
going to be the variable y and the
magnitude of vector V is going to be
equal to Phi all right I think I can
digest all of that and it says fill in
the blanks to complete the following
sentences so they're saying vector
vector W right over here and they didn't
have to actually write the word vector
they have an arrow on top of the W so we
know it's a vector so vector W is its
components are 3 x + 3 y so it's X
component is 3 times the X component of
vector V and it's Y component is 3 times
the Y component of vector V instead of
having a Y it has a 3y stead of having
an X it has a 3x so W is essentially
vector V being multiplied by the scalar
3 so it's magnitude is going to be 3
times the magnitude of vector V so if
vector V has a magnitude of 5 vector W
is going to have a magnitude of 15 it's
going to have 3 times the magnitude all
right now they tell us vector Z is equal
to so it's X component is negative 2
times the X component of vector V and
it's Y component is negative 2 times the
Y component of vector V so you could
view vector Z as negative 2 times vector
V or the scalar negative 2 times the
vector V and so you might say okay well
that means its magnitude is going to be
negative 2 times the magnitude of V but
you have to remember magnitude that's
always going to be positive you can one
way to think when we talk about even
absolute value what you really think
about the magnitude of something we're
talking about how long it is we're not
thinking about its direction so we
wouldn't think about the the the
negative there if we think about its
direction this negative is going to flip
its direction and we can think about
that in a second but if we just think
about magnitude we care about the two so
it's going to have two times the
magnitude
of vector V so instead of five it's
going to be 5 times 2 which is 10 so now
they say match each vector defined to a
vector that could be its equivalent so
if we think about it the vector with the
smallest magnitude is going to be vector
V the other two are we're multiplying
vector V by scalars with an absolute
value of more than 1 so they're going to
have larger magnitudes so the smallest
magnitude is this one right over here
this is the shortest vector so that
would be our vector V now vector W would
be one that has 3 times the magnitude
and it's going in the same direction so
this one has 3 times the magnitude it
looks like 3 times roughly and it's
definitely going in the same direction
and then vector Z would have 2 times the
magnitude but since we have we're
multiplying it times a negative scalar
it's going to go in the opposite
direction and this looks like it this
purple arrow looks like it's about twice
the length of this red arrow and it's
going in the opposite direction so I
feel pretty good about what we have done
here let's do one more of these so let's
let's do this one here so here we have a
vector V again it has a magnitude of 10
and it says fill in the blanks to
complete the following sentences vector
W now so now vector W it has its it's
taking each of the components of vector
V and multiplying them by 1/5 so you can
view a vector W as being equal to 1/5
the scalar 1/5 times vector V and so the
magnitude of W is going to be 1/5 the
magnitude of V so 1/5 of 10 is just
going to be 2
now vector Z it looks like it's 3/5
times vector V we're multiplying each of
the components times 3/5 so that's like
multiplying the entire vector by the
scalar 3/5 so it's magnitude is going to
be 3/5 the magnitude of vector V and so
3/5 of 10 is 6
all right then they say match each
vector defined above to a vector that
could be its equivalent so here the the
vector the largest magnitude is vector V
so this would be vector V
and the vector with the smallest
magnitude is vector W it's one-fifth the
magnitude so this has a magnitude should
be ten this should be one-fifth of that
which is a magnitude of two and it looks
like that and then this should be
three-fifths of the ten which is a
magnitude of six and that looks about
right so I feel good with what we have
filled out so hopefully that gives you a
sense of how to tackle these types of
types of example problems